[Musique]
bonjour au québec comme ailleurs dans le
monde des systèmes de justice civile
sont en crise en crise de confiance en
crise d'accessibilité 85 % des québécois
pensent que les riches sont favorisées
76% considèrent les délais trop longs
69 % n'ont pas les moyens de se
représenter devant les tribunaux et 50 2
% considèrent des jugements injustes
c'est plutôt inquiétant de voir ces
chiffres parce que dans une société
démocratique
le système de justice est un fondement
important c'est sûr que au cours des
différentes décennies les gouvernements
les institutions ont adopté différentes
mesures pour améliorer ce système mais
c'est complexe et ça change pas comme ça
mais moi justement comme chez avocat
depuis 30 ans j'ai vues différentes
modifications parce que je devenais
avocat et oui j'étais un jour plus jeune
et j'ai toujours frisé on pense à toutes
ces pratiques donc enlever ça et quand
j'ai commencé à pratiquer j'étais
content mais je t'adore j'étais très
naïve et j'ai commencé à distribuer les
cartes d'affaires et tous les coups j'ai
eu un coût au cas parce que je me suis
rendu compte que les avocats en avait
une mauvaise réputation vraiment très
mauvaise en réalité seulement 39% de la
population nous fait confiance
alors moi je n'avais rien fait encore
pire je trouvais que c'était dur mais
j'étais enthousiasme j'ai commencé à
plaider
et puis prêté au civil et j'ai gagné des
dossiers et oui et j'en ai perdu aussi
mais même quand je gagnais les clients
n'étaient pas contents ils n'étaient pas
contents pour toutes les raisons que je
vous dis mais surtout les rita majeur
c'était ma facture d'honoraires fait que
imaginer celui qui avait perdu
alors je me suis tourné vers la justice
alternative et j'ai commencé à
travailler dans une organisation qui
offrait des services d'arbitrage et de
médiation dans le privé il ya 26 ans au
québec on était vraiment des pionniers à
ce moment là et puis un jour j'ai décidé
de devenir médiatrice donc depuis 18 ans
que je médiatrice
gd plus d'un millier de personnes à
trouver des solutions à leur conflit et
puis en passant on règle en médiation 85
% le taux de réussite selon ministère du
travail de la justice
oui ce que je vais vous dire c'est que
dans le début de ma pratique assez
rapidement j'ai été confronté à un
dilemme
j'avais une coupe de voir - séparation
divorce
et puis je leur demande quelle est votre
intentions profondes en venant sans
médiation
vous voulez quoi profondément il se
regarde et me regarde on se regarde
qu'est-ce qui me disent on veut on veut
la justice et plus loin dans ma tête ça
fait le jeu
j'avais pas je me dis mais son temps
c'est pas la justice des tribunaux
puisqu'ils sont en médiation
est-ce qu'on va la trouver dans mon
bureau de médiation je suis pas trop
certes erne est-ce que - l'intérieur de
moi je suis c'est quoi la médiation pas
trop sûr j'étais endormi un cours de
droit mais en tout cas c'était pas clair
dans ma tête
alors j'ai décidé d'amorcer une quête de
sites comprendre mais c'est quoi la
justice
en fait il n'ya pas de définition unique
de la justice ça aurait été beaucoup
trop simple elle varie selon les époques
les sociétés les cultures donc mais park
ont des grands concepts que je vous
donnais socrates dit que la justice
c'est comme l'amour
c'est l'une des deux plus grandes vertus
alors c'est un idéal c'est un absolu
bon ça c'est difficile d'application
alors certains ont dit on a jusqu à
appliquer le droit les lois et justice
sera rendue
mais encore est ce que ce sera est-ce
que rodez concept de moralité d'équité
d'égalité dit sic d'administration de la
justice
oh non c'est pas si clair que ça mais
moi ma plus grande découverte a été
celle ci c'est que dans le fond moi vous
chacun de vous avons à l'intérieur de
nous un tribunal et tim un sens profond
de la justice et que lorsque deux trois
ou même plusieurs individus se
réunissent ensemble pour parler autour
d'une table dolor besoins de leurs
intérêts de leur valeur dans leurs
croyances de leur religion dans leur
perception de leur interprétation pee
wee pourrait parler de leurs droits
aussi s'empêche pas ça ben on va trouver
ensemble des solutions des solutions
mutuellement satisfaisante créative
originale est censée la justice privée
vraiment satisfaisante
vous allez peut-être penser ouais mais
les juges qu'est ce qu'ils font c'est
quoi lol c'est pas bon la justice public
parce que je monte un petit diagramme
d'enfants la justice privée ça a
toujours existé un système informel
beaucoup plus rapide ou un dispendieux
et puis à côté de la justice public un
système formel et le jeu lui y rendent
décision en droit
temis il prend son épée joc i tranche
est en tête qui tombe bien une qui
restent debout ça saigne - solo mais je
de la tête qui roule à vos pots dire
justin st avold crier à l'injustice
mais ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
c'est absolument essentiel
ces décisions de justice ont de droit en
fait des éditions endroits sont
essentiels
pour que parce que tout n'est pas mais
diable tout n'est pas négociable non
plus on a besoin des alignements nos
besoins des tribunaux et ça nous permet
aussi de rendre une justice privée de
qualité et ces deux systèmes le sont
complémentaires l'un à l'autre la
justice privée ça a toujours existé et
si on n'avait pas ça ne pourrait pas
fonctionner dans système public alors et
la justice participative c'est de dire
regardons l'ensemble et voyons sur la
complémentarité et du système informel
jusqu'aux systèmes formels il ya une
gamme de services qui peuvent être
faites aux citoyens et participent trois
citoyens à trouver une solution
d'autant plus que au 1er janvier 2016 le
code de procédure civile a été modifiée
au québec
le juge richard wagner de la cour
suprême modiste un véritable changement
de culture
c'est une réforme majeure et inédite bon
je suis d'accord avec lui et il s'est
dit d'accord mais c'est quoi la réforme
c'est que on est venu dire la justice
fut privé dorénavant vous devez la
considérer citoyens avocat avant d'aller
d'un système public
vous devez faire un effort de
négociation de médiation de règlement
dans le privé alors que le procès a
toujours été le premier maire de premier
réflexe ça devient le dernier des moyens
imaginez vous les avocats qui ont été
formés pour être des gladiateurs
maintenant on vous demande d'être des
guerriers pacifique
waouh du coup quel changement de culture
oh là là mais là il ya des gens qui ont
dit un oui mais ça va prendre 10 ans 15
ans on peut pas changer une culture
comme ça moi ça m'a choqué parce que
dans le fond je me dis c'est ce qu'il
faut faire mais faisons le et j'ai pensé
mais qu'est ce que ça prend pour changer
une culture
la première chanson je pense hélas
prendre de la formation et de
l'information à la population que les
citoyens sachent que la justice avec un
grand j -c pas toujours possible ok
qu'il ait des attentes réalistes par
rapport au système c'est bien sûr que
j'invite mes consoeurs et confrères
avocats
à changer leurs pratiques je pense que
nous avons une opportunité
extraordinaire de regagner la confiance
de la population et de changer nos
façons de pratiquer il ya là une
opportunité à saisir
enfin c'est bien sûr que des grandes
institutions je pense au ministère de la
justice
conseil de la magistrature le barreau du
québec les facultés de droit doivent
soutenir et embarqué dans le changement
dans leur sphère d'activité dans leur
sphère d'influencé
et puis j'ai un rêve pourquoi que de la
maternelle jusqu'à la sixième année y
aurait pas des cours sur la
communication sur la négociation
raisonnée sur l'empathie des cours
obligatoires
imaginez-vous changements qu'on aurait
et puis j'aime encore des pacificateurs
médiateur dans tous les milieux de
travail
on prendrait le conflit à sa racine ce
serait merveilleux pour faire un
changement de culture justice
participative pour plus d'humanité
oui moi j'y crois parce que lorsqu'on a
un intérieur de soi un sentiment de paix
que ce lait sont vides les justices on
n'est pas en paix mais quand on est en
paix quand on ne se sentiments à
l'intérieur de soi on peut être bien
dans son couple
on peut être bien dans sa femme et on
peut être bien dans son travail
on peut être bien dans sa communauté ce
qui est intéressant c'est que ça donne
et fait contamination on devient des
modèles pour nos enfants parce que le
mieux-être collectif
ça passe aussi par un mieux être
individuel d'abord et avant tout par un
mieux être individuel est alors des
grands défis économiques sociologiques
démographique environnementaux est-ce
qu'on a du temps à perdre tant que ça
devant les tribunaux je ne crois pas est
ce que le temps ne serait pas à la
négociation à la médiation pourquoi pas
moi en faisant ces petites conférences
j'ai voulu apporter ma pierre à
l'édifice
mon ma contribution au changement
si vous croyez que cette idée vaut la
peine d'être partagée bien à vous et
surtout merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]